good evening everybody my name is Mark
call Toph I share the history department
here at Hillsdale College and it's my
delight to welcome you here to the Marke
law at Orion for our guest lecture this
evening this of course is Constitution
Day it was 228 years ago today that the
Constitutional Convention wrapped up its
business and they signed the document
they did so without some small actually
fairly large communication and
discussion about this new office of the
presidency the Electoral College being
one of the chief innovations of this new
office of the executive and some were
scared by it George Mason said that he
suspected he smelled in the executive of
the fetus of a monarchy whether or not
over the subsequent centuries the
executive has become that is I leave for
you to judge but perhaps our speaker
this evening will be able to shed some
light on that question as the
presidential debate of last night is
conditioning the news of today I'm sure
he will have some things to say Victor
Davis Hanson is the Martin and Ellie
Anderson senior fellow in residence in
classics and military history at the
Hoover Institution of Stanford
University he is a professor emerges of
classics at Cal State University Fresno
and a nationally syndicated columnist
for the Tribune Media Services and
happily he is also the Wayne and Marsha
busky distinguished fellow in history
here at Hillsdale College where for some
12 years now every fall he comes and
teaches a course in the fall semester
he's in the middle of teaching a course
on leadership ancient and modern now and
that will wrap up next week dr. Hanson
earned his BA in classics at the
University of California Santa Cruz he
studied at the American School of
Classical Studies in Athens and earned
his PhD in classical studies at Stanford
University he's the author of hundreds
of articles book reviews and scholarly
papers that range on topics from ancient
Greek agrarian and military history to
foreign affairs domestic politics and
contemporary culture he is also written
or edited no fewer than 22 books
including the other Greeks the family
farm and the
arian roots of Western civilization the
soul of battle
who killed homer the demise of classical
education and the recovery of Greek
wisdom Mexifornia a state of becoming
and many others he is of course written
widely for the National Review The
Washington Times The Wall Street Journal
the New York Times and many others as he
has appeared on National Public Radio
PBS Newshour Fox News CNN and many
others so please join me in welcoming
dr. Victor Davis Hanson who tonight will
speak on the topic reflections on the
GOP presidential debates and prospects
for the 2016 election Vicki
thank you very much mark this is my 12th
year that I've that I come from
California and it's besides the the
radical change in climate because it has
rained I think three inches this year in
California which is less than it has
since I've been here and this is a dry
year for you guys
Mark's been Mike sort of contact here at
Hillsdale so we've developed a habit
what do you do I call him in May or June
and get the classes worked out the
lectures I was booked I was going to
talk on World War two and when I got
here he came up with the idea of the
debate and I thought I would speak for
about 25 or 30 minutes and have an open
house because usually when you talk
about these candidates it gets pretty
intense and it's it's fun as you saw in
some of the the give-and-take and I
promise that I won't say tremendous I'll
make your head spin absolutely wonderful
awesome like some of the candidates you
know this whole debate is framed on the
record whether we explicitly or
implicitly a Barack Obama and it's going
to be a great challenge for the next
president of either party how to do deal
with it if you look at the Middle East
the president said that Yemen was a
model of anti-terrorism policy and then
it collapsed three weeks after he said
that and in Libya we were told leading
from behind was a model and then Hillary
said we came we saw he died and chuckled
about the execution of Qaddafi and then
the whole country turned into Mogadishu
on the Mediterranean and then whatever
one felt about the Iraq war by the time
Obama entered office the average monthly
death toll in Iraq was less than the
accident rate of the US military and
getting out of Iraq in 2011 for an
election talking point would have been
saying it would have been as if
Eisenhower was up for re-election in
1956 and he just pulled everybody out of
Korea and said the things been over for
four years they don't need us and you
can imagine
that would have entailed you wouldn't
have Kia today you'd have something like
North Korea all the way down to Pusan
and so the Middle East and I don't even
need to mention Isis that we were told
was the JV organization Assad was a
reformer he had a red line he wasn't
supposed to cross a game-changing red
line that he did all of the assurances
we were given about the Iran deal that
there would be Anytime Anywhere
inspections there would be no
centrifuges whatsoever there would be no
enriched uranium whatsoever there would
be all protocols side agreements via the
UN would be shown to the Congress have
proved to be null and void if you look
at the economy the Federal Reserve today
said they're not going to increase
interest rates that's the longest period
we've had essentially if you calibrate
inflation zero inflation rate and that's
really taken a toll on people who some
of you may have 2030 middle-class people
like all of us if you have 40 50
thousand in the bank you're essentially
losing money every month in on it and
you have a choice between either plane
and the stock market if you look at your
401k lately
everything's been eaten away since
January 1st that if it did gain and then
our play in the real estate market
because you're gonna lose money by being
silver injudicious thrifty and exemplary
and it's putting away money and putting
it in a passbook account the economy is
not in a great position we have to we
have the highest number of people who
are not looking for a job 91 million
americans have dropped out of the labor
force what I'm most worried about it not
is not just the economy and not just a
foreign policy but and it came up a
little bit but not nearly enough and the
debate is the attitude toward the law I
really I don't think that we we're like
Venezuela or the Congo or maybe
revolutionary France in the 18th century
a law that has been passed by Congress
and signed into effect by the president
no longer
matters I'll give you a couple example
what would you think if we if a
Republican president came in and treated
the IRS the way Lois Lerner did if we
had a high-ranking bureaucrat who went
after all the left-wing nonprofits and
then pled the fifth and she still
escaped from consequences of the law or
what if a president decided that the EPA
all of those regulations were going to
have as much statutory effect as ice
does just as there's no longer an
immigration law enforced we won't even
enforce the EPA the idea that over 300
cities in the United States would adopt
the Confederate 18:59 idea of
nullification that they were exempt from
federal law with sanctuary cities could
you imagine if Hillsdale said to the
next president well we decided that the
Endangered Species Act doesn't apply
within the confines of Hillsdale and
we're gonna let you kill a newt or
woodpecker it just doesn't apply we're
exempt from enforcement of federal law
there'd be outrage or if the next
president said you know what Barack
Obama decided to pick and choose which
elements of Obama care and I don't
really want to take the trouble to have
it repealed through Congress so I'm just
going to announce certain things that I
don't like null and void we could go on
but you see where we're going it's a
very scary time where the force of the
law the sanctity of the law depends on
whether it's synonymous with a
perception of revolutionary justice or
social choice and if it isn't then it's
not to be enforced so it's a very it's a
very strange time in this election
remember its until Joe Biden jumps into
this election it's what we call an
orphaned election there is not an
incumbent president or vice president in
the race we haven't had one we hadn't
had one excuse me until 2008 since 1952
and when usually when you have one it
favors the out party in other words when
Harry Truman did not run for what would
have been de facto a third term
officially a second but it would put him
in office eleven
it turned out that Eisenhower and
Stevenson both ran against him and that
benefited Eisenhower when nobody ran in
2008 Dick Cheney couldn't run or didn't
want to and Bush was at the end of his
term then McCain ended up running as
much against bush as had Obama that
favored Obama because you don't want
your guide to trash your guy you might
as well vote for the other person if
this is an orphaned election you can see
that Hillary Clinton will be and she's
already done and she's already announced
that the middle class is shrinking
they have hadn't had a fair deal the
middle-east isn't what it should be and
even Biden before he's a candidate has
mentioned that so that's going to be
something to watch but I have a feeling
that the Democratic candidate will be as
critical as of the incumbent as McCain
was a bush and that's not good for the
Democratic prospect and it's a rare
phenomenon in American history orphaned
elections a couple of other things I
think are important we don't know what
the key issues or I just mentioned the
Obama record because I feel that the law
or the sanctity of the law and you feel
that and the economy the stagnant
economy and the disaster in the Middle
East you woke up one day and Israel was
not just a not an ally maybe not in
neutral but the president States has
more invective against Netanyahu than he
does culminate Khamenei and Iran it's
almost as if it's an enemy now it's an
alternate universe it's it's flipped
right before our eyes and these are
issues but doesn't mean necessarily
they're going to be the issues we don't
know what they're going to be in the
autumn in 2008 Obama crafted a campaign
based on Iraq but it was a stupid war
and he was attacking Hillary Clinton all
through the primary on her vote for it
and then meanwhile insidiously
incrementally David Petraeus surge was
working and so we got to June of 2008
and that month nobody was killed in Iraq
and suddenly Obama erased his website
with all references that we should bring
everybody home from March 2008 and the
issue as soon as Hillary lost the
nomination
was dead we didn't know what the issue
was we forget but I confirmed today
because I couldn't believe it that on
September 13th for the third sink sec
you t'v week John McCain and Sarah Palin
were ahead of Barack Obama it was very
late in the campaign and they were
making enormous inroads on the fact that
Obama's Iraq ideas were bankrupt he had
said bad things about the surge the
surge had worked he had no experience
and if you look at the various polls
it's anywhere from two and a half to
five percent and it was pretty steady
for three weeks on September 14th there
was a new issue that nobody anticipated
Goldman Sachs imploded and for the next
week Wall Street firm after Wall Street
firm looked like it was going to be
bankrupt Ford Motor Company went down to
$2 a share and suddenly there were had
to be a reaction toward that and the
exit Jesus that John McCain should have
said that this was because of subprime
loans that were guaranteed by Freddie
Mae and Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and
that's a long complicated explanation
and when Obama just said Bush did it and
Obama's Bush did it and McCain's part of
it and then McCain panicked and said we
should suspend the debates or I'll
suspend my campaign for a week you
remember that and within 48 hours that
four point lead dissipated to one point
within 72 hours they were equal and
within four to five days
Obama was ahead by three and within two
weeks he was ahead by seven and he never
relinquished that lead that's an example
of an issue that may come up in
September we don't know right now what
North Korea is gonna be doing we have no
idea if all this crazy talk might become
serious that some day god forbid in
October we don't know what the Iranians
will do we don't know what Blatter burm
Putin will do he could go into Estonia
on September 1st we have no idea what
Isis might do here at home another 9/11
we don't know what the economy will be
likely there will be an issue in other
words that will be of fundamental
importance that we probably are don't
even
I know what it is and it will change the
election a couple of other things before
we look at the the candidates this sub
this campaign has very strange
demographics you heard after McCain II
followed McCain that old white guys in
the Republican Party were not the future
of America we heard that again and again
again we were told that Ronald Reagan
won because the electorate in 1980 was
85% so-called white now forget for a
minute that I don't know what white
means anymore and my family we have two
people married to mexican-americans we
have Asians it's just like everybody's
family especially in California but if
you were to accept that left-wing
version that we all have DNA badges that
make us a particular race based on the
percentage it still is a very strange
argument because what's happened is
Obama came in in 2008 with a community
organizing principle I'm going to slice
the electorate by gender life of Julia
remember that little tape he did he did
that in 2012 Sandra Fluke the urbanize
young emancipated woman versus the
grabby married woman with four kids out
in the Michigan countryside on the idea
there were more young women that of the
former than the latter and then he diced
us by gay and straight he said twice
that he believed in the sanctity of
traditional marriage and then when it
came time he that was no longer
operative but the big divide was he
looked at the demography and he said you
know what there's 15% fewer white people
and all of a sudden in 2008 we heard
Reverend Wright that he could no long no
more disown Reverend Wright than his own
mother his own grandmother his own
grandmother was called typical white
person the clingers in Pennsylvania get
in their face I'll bring a gun to a
knife fight and then as the presidency
there was the skip gates the Trayvon
Martin son that he never had
the Latinos were supposed to punish our
enemies I'm quoting directly and then
there was a disparagement of Romney it
was all predicated that he no longer as
a traditional Democrat needed to worry
so much about the white vote as long as
it was 42 to 43 percent and it would
never go back down to the the
percentages of Reagan I think high the
lowest that Democrats ever got was 35%
of a very large white boat in 1984 when
there was the wipeout of Walter Mondale
but what Obama did not count on and the
Democratic Party is very worried is the
level of rhetoric rhetorical attacks on
quote unquote
old white men white privilege the
necessary attacks to get phenomenal
participation by so-called minorities I
mean there was a 66% registration rate
of blacks 96% of blacks voted for Barack
Obama
Asians voted who were sort of split
before at 71% Hispanics were 72% and it
looked like that theory was I'm not
talking about the morality of the ethics
I'm just looking at the efficacy it
looked like it was a winning strategy
but it was predicated on two things one
that that Minority allegiance in such
unusual and historical numbers was
absolutely transferable to somebody
other than Obama if you look at the
Democratic field it's exactly what they
used to criticize the Republicans for
because if you take away Hillary an old
white woman you have an old white Joe
Biden and you haven't really old white
socialist Bernie Sanders and then you've
got a kind of white middle-aged guy
named O'Malley and a kind of white old
guy named Webb and then you got three
old white guys called Jerry Brown and Al
Gore and John Kerry and waiting if they
need them and it's not what they said if
you look at the Republican also you know
Bobby Jindal Ted Cruz more
Rubio ben Carson Carly Fiorina so it
suggests that that might not be true
that when Obama's not on the ticket all
of that but rhetorical demagoguing might
not transfer the same levels and there's
no margin of error now because if you
look at the polls he's done what nobody
thought would be possible
he's got the white vote below 40% down
to Reagan levels almost for the
Democrats if the white vote should get
down from I think it was 39% in the last
election which he won by 3% if it goes
down to 36% and I think it might well
then it won't matter how much
participation even Obama would not win
at that rate but surely not one of his
successor so that's something to watch
and what we will expect to see in the
election is we will try to see Hillary
and Bernie Sanders with the black lives
matter hands up don't shoot all of that
stuff about immigration and I stand with
you on the border and then suddenly and
magically when the primaries are over if
it's Hillary she will be me Annie Oakley
mood again about Boilermakers and
shooting and bowling again and I don't
think it's going to work I really do a
couple of other things about the debate
and especially Trump debates I know I
was exhausted by three hours the debate
formats not working in the sense that
you had the JV debate to use Obama's
terms about jayvees and earlier two
hours but you gave more percentage
airtime to the second tier four than you
did to the top 11 and I and here's a
situation where I agree with Donald
Trump that three hours is too long
you heard everything you needed in the
first two out that said if you have a
good field a good field then the debates
are energizing in the sense that this
was the highest-rated CNN newscast
they'd ever had in the debate forum and
and Fox had been the highest that Fox
has ever had both were higher than any
other debate format except the general
election it was a wrecker
partly because of obviously because of
Donald Trump's presence but the point
I'm making is if you have good
candidates the Republicans do have good
candidates then it makes sense to have a
debate every month if you don't and I
think a good example would be 2012 when
you had Herman Cain and Michelle Bachman
and John Huntsman and Rick Santorum and
Newt Gingrich then 20 of them have the
depressing effect and people saw how
mediocre the Republican feel was this
time they're getting a monthly dose of
how good it is and by the same token
just six democratic debates is going to
hurt them so the number of the debates I
think this time was the right number and
the candidate field was was much better
and then before we look at each of the
candidates and I do want to have time
for a question answer there's this
phenomenon called Trump you know he's
kind of like haagen-dazs ice cream isn't
he that it tastes good you feel good
it's sweet and you know that if you were
to continue it it's not sustainable or
good for your health and you can't keep
doing it but in the meantime every dark
thought you might have had it come
across your mind but you wouldn't dare
say he says for you so he's a presence
and before we laugh him off if any of us
were given The Apprentice and said it's
your TV show none of us could make it
last for 11 years that's very hard to
make a reality TV show do that so he has
he's a showman and I know that it's he
has these eponymous buildings everywhere
and he's I made this many billion and
it's awesome and it's tremendous and
I'll do but the fact is in today's
cutthroat business world I don't think
he's worth 10 I don't think he's working
at 8 I believe sober assessments he's
worth 4 but to have four billion dollars
in net worth even if you inherited a
billion in a world that really you don't
make money unless you're in finance
insurance hedge funds and he's actually
building something suggests to me that
he does have talent a lot of talent and
so it's very
intricate how to deal with him if you're
a Republican because on that stage last
night everybody in their dark mind knew
that if Trump had not been there half
the people would not be watching them
and yet they knew that if they were to
attack Trump he would attack in Mitali
with much more vigor and Trump's very
brilliant how he's run this campaign he
looks for fissures in the seams of the
other candidates and then he exploits
them he's never once attacked a
candidate first he waits to a candidate
just makes an offer off hands slightly
marked like John McCain did or megyn
kelly or anybody and then he goes after
it and he's also he picks his victims at
least until Carly Fiorina very carefully
now I thought what he said about John
McCain was outrageous
but then I thought I was driving with a
person they said he's done I said no
he's not done and the reason is that
again all of you and your deep dark
thoughts you would never voice that but
you got a little tired of him work
waving the bloody shirt and as gross and
callous as that was he got away with it
and megyn kelly I thought was really
buffoonish and and uncalled for and
crude what he said about megyn kelly but
deep down inside you thought you know
the fox blonde bombshell is getting a
little old that I'm not supposed to say
that but I really don't believe there
are legal scholars and PhDs and
brilliant with short dresses and fake
tans and blonde hair so when he implies
one is a bimbo we liked it watch
gladiators and the arena fight it out
and that's what he did I think he kind
of crossed the line with Fiorina and now
he's in a matrix or a paradox of his own
creation and that is he doesn't want to
prep like Carly Fiorina so he doesn't
know the issues I think you know whether
you're for him or against him you agree
with that and he has a particular style
of bomb bass and invective and he says
politically incorrect things he's
wonderful at that he gets people
energized but he's got to do that for 12
for 12 debates and he if he doesn't
transform that energy into an
advancement of her particular agenda or
issue
in some detail it's going to get old or
if other candidates as happened last
night have the issues and they're
starting to peel off his emotions and
act more like Trump than Trump is like
them in other words it seems to me that
Christie and Fiorina and Rubio and all
of them are acting more like Trump his
style his energy level and he's acting
less like their strengths their
knowledge of the issues so he's going to
have to do a couple of things and that
is either master the issues while
keeping up the energy level and or he's
going to have to keep doing what he's
doing and you can see by three hours of
it he got tired of it and then he was
nice and at the end he was gentlemanly
he was funny he did a high-five he took
all the attacks and he was deflated and
when he walked off the last hour after
dominating the first two hours he'd
become a different Trump a normal nice
guy and he'd lost the attraction because
he's created his own caricature of
himself he's going to have to continue
or become a serious candidate and if he
doesn't do the necessary homework then
his strengths are going to be nullified
I'd like to go over the Democratic group
first I made fun of him his old white
guys in it and they basically are I
think Joe Biden may get in but he does I
mean it's very funny about him we don't
associate a 70 72 year-old white guy as
part of the establishment for 40 years
which he is and he hasn't a unique
ability he's he's at twice plagiarist he
plagiarized in college and was punished
for it and he plagiarized on his first
campaign for presidency and dropped out
and he made it quaint plagiarism is just
old Joe and he said some very callous
racial stupid things about the disabled
and people and he's just old Joe and
he's habitually wrong about politics
whether it's you know he said that Iraq
would be the administration's greatest
achievement except to accept it and he's
wrong but it doesn't he for all of his
aggravating style he has an endearing
quality that
protected him a Teflon nature so if he
were to run and just the mention of him
has already propelled him from 3 to 20%
he's he's almost even in the national
polls with Bernie Sanders so I think
that there's something about him that I
don't think it will win here in the
national election but when we we think
of all the stupid things he said I mean
he he actually said George Bush should
get on TV and address the nation after
the financial collapse in the same way
that FDR in 1929 got on the television
when FDR was not present there was no
TVs so and we gave him we forgave him
that's just Joe if George Bush had said
that he would be considered a [ __ ]
they're talking about Jerry Brown have
you heard that
III know a lot about him I had this sort
of habit until we of any time I wrote on
California which is quite often about
every eight weeks I get a phone call for
this very strange voice whenever a
barrage of invectives you did this and
you don't know anything it was Jerry
Brown and it sounded more and more
shrill and you almost think that if he
actually comes out here at the age of 76
it's almost as if he comes out of a time
work out of cyber genex or something and
says I will pledge to protect the earth
serve the people and explore space you
kids are too young but that's what he
did and 1992 was very funny and he
hasn't changed at all it's almost like
he's in a time warp and he's don't think
that he's not seriously considering it I
don't know who lincoln Chafee is you
hear the name Chafee who's lincoln
Chafee I mean that's I guess to answer
that question we have to ask why George
Pataki is running is it for Secretary of
Commerce or some I don't know does
anybody think that Al Gore would
actually dare do it the last time we we
heard of Al Gore he sold his cable
station that was failing for 50 million
dollars after acquiring a net worth of a
half a billion dollars on the idea the
planet
was heating up and suffocating from
carbon he sold this bankrupt cable
company to al-jazeera an anti-semitic
state megaphone from gutter whose income
that went into the Al Gore coffers came
from oil products and he did so to rush
the sale to beat the new capital gains
tax so here's a big government hike tax
guy trying to beat capital gains tax and
selling to put a person according to his
own philosophy pollutes the earth and is
quite anti-american if you've ever
watched al-jazeera's I don't think
that's serious John Kerry we've heard of
them you notice one thing about these
candidates is that not only are they old
and they're white and they're male
they've all lost they've all run before
we all said we don't want retreads Jerry
Brown for present he lost Joe Biden ran
for president he never made it John
Kerry ran for president he lost Algor
won the popular vote but he lost so why
are we in Hillary Clinton ran for
president he lost
they have except for Jerry Brown they
have no geographical diversity they have
no gender except for Hillary they're all
from that eastern seaboard and they're
all that fossilized the ossified
calcified Democratic Party that had been
in politics for years and then I think
Kerry's motto would be you know after
the saran deal falls apart I on I was
for the Iran deal before I'm against it
because I know that's coming he's going
to he's going to say that Bernie Sanders
is a tired socialist insider and he's
running as a fresh populist outsider and
I don't think that's gonna work
he's a very endearing guy he's he really
believes that socialism is the answer
but most people realize that for all the
glitz about Barack Obama he came in with
super majorities in the house and a big
majority in the Senate and nobody in the
last 50 years has done more damage to
this and destroyed the Democratic Party
like
Barack Obama he lost the house he lost
his Senate he's lost 2/3 of the state
legislatures he's lost 62% of the
governorships and I think if you look at
these paradigms between you know Salt
Lake City or Houston versus Detroit in
Chicago or California versus Nevada or
Florrick people see these contrasts or
the EU versus what used to be the United
States they don't think that that
paradigm of statism or socialism is very
convincing Hillary now finished with her
you all had never Oscar Wilde's novel of
Picture of Dorian Gray we all thought
that was Bill Clinton the sins of his
life were starting to appear in his
wrinkles but it actually if you see her
it's actually Hillary Clinton it's
almost as if the more thinks he's done
she has a psychological tic have you
noticed that that she'll mention
something and then you'll say yes that's
right you did that and she'll say we
need Trent the other night she said we
need transparency I thought yes you're
not transparent with your email and then
she said and hedge funds make more than
kindergarten teachers I think yes they
do and Chelsea made 15 million dollars
in hedge funds and you worked you rented
an office in a hedge fund office
building soon as you came out of office
and your son-in-law is worth 20 million
out of hedge funds and when she says
these things you just you know she I
don't want to get into that but I I'm
trying to be funny tonight and she said
just the other day I watched a video did
you see it about sexual assault she said
you can say it you can be believed you
don't have to apologize you can make
them take I thought wow Juanita
Broderick Paula Jones Monica Lewinsky
what was the whole paradigm of the
Clinton machine it was that these women
were trailer trash you put out a $10
bill they came out of their trailers
they had been falsely a Kippur bill so
it's really kind of a caricature that
almost everything she said is a
referendum on her past life the last one
I really liked is when she said students
student loans are too high and students
are got a trillion dollar in debt it's
because the universities are spending
too much money she went down to UCLA in
charge UCLA for 30 minutes 10
and dollars a minute for a hackneyed 28
minute lecture about her life I mean who
could think of how many students could
have you know gone to school you could
have had ten students tuition paid for
that 30-minute harangue so she's got a
real problem and I'm if you compare her
their other candidate I haven't
mentioned his Elizabeth Warren but how
is don't you believe that Elizabeth
Warren looks 20 years younger than
Hillary even though she sounds thirty
years older because he's a granny scold
but she's actually just a year and a
half younger and it's phenomenal that as
I said she's Hillary's becoming Dorian
Gray getting to the you saw all the the
Republican candidates last night I don't
know what is about Jeb Bush I do some of
these radio shows Mark Levin and and
Laura Ingraham and if I've had a little
bit to drink even Michael Savage once in
a while and on tape first but you talked
to these guys during the break and they
have a pathological hatred of George I
mean that Jeb Bush it's not it's not a
understand the frustration of the
Democratic I mean the Republican
establishment is John Boehner and Mitch
McConnell kind of like bluestocking
Republican characters in the 1950s but
it's really strange that if they were to
nominate Jeb Bush the greatest anger
would come from Republicans and yet
watching him last night you get the
feeling that he really did have a
consent the more he tells us the details
of his conservative record in Florida
and a more conservative that he has
searched that he is the less natural he
seems to be a conservative how does he
do that I don't know but he's done it
and he's a very nice guy and he's a very
conservative guy but the more he
explains why we don't believe he's
conservative I don't know what to say
about ben Carson all only that we have
not had an outlier a non-professional
since dwight d eisenhower
also in the fifty-two orphaned election
so maybe that sixty-four year tradition
is valuable rather than as to in need of
change because
it's gonna be very hard for Fiorina and
Trump and Carson not that they can't do
it but I don't think any of them have
the accomplishments of leading the d-day
invasion of Europe and it's and that's
gonna be hard part of the problem with a
candidate like Carson he's very talented
but you don't want everybody to be
rooting for him silence that if you just
speak up a little louder and that's what
your our reactions are that he's so
reflective and contemplative and then he
also on the issues he has the first 75
percent right and you want him to stop
and don't go into a detailed analysis of
foreign policy because it's gonna end up
loony when he talks about immigration
you'll say just stop don't get into the
becerril program of the 1950's because
they ever have any idea that we had this
song called deportee or CBS harvest of
shame or i grew up with the Paseos when
he talks about guest workers and
agriculture you're getting into that
whole 50 60 reform movement that's not
wise I don't know what Lindsey Graham's
point is that he has a point for the
candidacy is anybody know what it is I
don't know why he's running is it to a
neocon I don't know what it is but maybe
you do I wrote a little thing down for
Huckabee I kind of like Huckabee and I
wrote would that his noble creed be
inductively inferred rather than
deductive Lee applied and that by that I
meant I'd like to know that he was a
Christian by his positions on the issues
after he gave them I could surmise that
he's very christian-like rather than be
told in advance he's a Christian then
that Christianity fit all the issues are
made them fit and so whether he's very a
very good speaker and he's very quick on
his feet as we knew from his show but
he's got this idea that everything is
going to be seen in this particular
religious prism and then he applies that
to the issues rather than just not
mention it and you after three hours you
would say God based on what he said on
the issue that guy is very
christian-like
but you wouldn't want to be told out
deductively in advance
Carly Fiorina I just watched TV before I
came here she's exploding everybody says
you know she was but I looked at the
polls today before they debate and she
was that 3% I come from California where
Barbara Boxer wiped her out by 10
percent lead but she ran a good campaign
she did better than meg Whitman did
against Jerry Brown and then I live I
work in a city where most of some of the
I shouldn't say most but a lot of the
donors who we have to work with at the
Hoover Institution were associated with
our new members of you at Packard when
she was CEO and I think that'll come out
that she's not a popular person in
Silicon Valley I think maybe
unjustifiably so but my question and
maybe you can in the question answer
answer that isn't to me of all the
candidates last night she seemed the
wittiest she seemed the most informed
she seemed the most knowledgeable she
seemed the boldest she seemed to most
had the most appropriate response to
Donald Trump and then I said - in my
head and now what now what so she gets
out in that debate is she just keep
doing this each debate or does she
transform herself into a Trump on the
campaign just got big spectacles and she
gets people all excited and she takes on
people I don't know but I do know that
of all the debaters she's the best
debater but I don't know if that
translates into raising a lot of money
yet and conducting a very brilliant
campaign on the stump as the anti
Hillary I'm just gonna finish with the
minor kami bobby Jindal you know what
never in the history of I'm quoting
churchill now i'm blair ER and he was
here would like that never have you been
able to learn so much from so much so
quickly from just one person and regret
the experience of going through that and
i don't know what it is about him but
every time i listen to him he knows
almost everything and he's able to tell
you that in about 30 seconds in such a
way that it's mind-numbing and you you
go away exhausted and depressed so i
don't think that he's going to make it
same thing about case each i'm really
impressed I think you are with his
soberness and judicious Ness every issue
he takes the high road I would just like
to read about it rather than actually
hear him because he sounds like an uncle
that scolds you all I had an uncle like
that on the farm and he would come in
and he'd say now Victor let me show you
how to put a PTO shaft onto the machine
and then the next thing I knew he was
giving me a lecture about everything
about my dress my attitude my language
and he was scolding me and that's that's
the way
KCH comes across I think and yet the
election will be won as you know there's
only about eight states that are purple
states now and we can talk all we want
about Texas being a red state but it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter how
much the minority and Latinos vote
against the Republican but they're not
gonna win Texas by the same token you
could go out to California a hundred
times if you're Carly Fiorina and be a
native daughter and you're not gonna win
California you're gonna do the the
election is going to be decided in
Florida Ohio Colorado New Mexico maybe
places like Oregon Pennsylvania Michigan
but and you're gonna need a candidate so
in theory
everybody said kch Walker Rubio that
gives you the states and that was part
of the attraction for case each Rand
Paul you know Rand Paul has a young
quirky sense of intelligence he is very
smart squicky though and he has a
quicker way of talking have you noticed
that and he's one quirk away each minute
he talks and being creepy and scary and
you don't know when that quirks gonna
happen and that's my view of him I mean
when he started when he mentions the
Middle East his eyes get big and I
thought you know or he mentions the
police have too much machinery and body
armor and I think that's it be quiet
he's kind of scary if not creepy Rubio
everybody likes Rubio I do he's the best
argument that experience doesn't matter
isn't it he can if he gets nominated you
we can make the argument that as the
Democrats did with Obama that he
experienced you don't need experience
he's
every other requisite he's a great
speaker he's brilliant but he doesn't
have an executive experience and he's
not and you saw that I think when he got
leverage in the immigration debate by
Schumer I like Rick Santorum every time
I see him talk don't you think if it was
just true that we could go back to the
1950s I I if he could be President and
hit a button say we're back in 1958 I'd
vote for him but he can't and we're
never gonna be able to go back to his
world I wish we could but every time I
see him he keeps talking about all these
things I grew up with and I thought you
know what it's dead and all of your
effort and all they're not gonna bring
it back whether we like it or not I
mentioned from he's like haagen-dazs or
as I said a martini it's taste good it's
fun but it's gonna kill you if you keep
at it
now finish with the Scott walk or
somebody that you guys know a lot better
than I do I'll just say a brief sentence
about him every time I hear him I'm at
California and I realized why I like the
sheriff and the movie Fargo you know he
sounds like her he's sensible he's
honest and yet I don't think I could I
don't think he's gonna he's going to
inspire people yet so let me conclude
and we'll have some questions who what
are we looking at the odds are probably
that Hillary will be nominated with all
of this flow we keep we keep saying her
polls are diving and even pundits that
are as skilled as Nate silver of
mathematicians statisticians have have
charted heard all the way down but she's
still 20 points ahead of Bernie Sanders
and the questions not is Hillary gonna
be nominated but there's no Barack Obama
this year so she has no competition so
the odds are likely that she will be
nominated her fate depends entirely on
how Valerie Jarrett gets up every
morning and feels in the White House
because if she could see something that
she doesn't like and there's a lot not
to like about Hillary especially as she
begins to triangulate against Barack
Obama then she can get on the phone and
have the just Department leaked more
information that they
out the more that is leaked than this
it's like a forest fire that leaps up
again with the emails it the email thing
will not be solved because she can't
tell the truth because to tell the truth
would reveal things that she did was not
only illegal but unethical and we look
at Petraeus we look at people the
intelligence community that we know that
would behind bars so that she her
candidate as a candidate she's viable to
the agree that we can just settle this
thing down the media cooperates and that
depends on the embalmer ministration not
trying to become nihilistic if Biden
gets in the race who knows what they
would do so I think she will be the
nominee and I think all of us on the
conservative side want a ticket with a
couple of things they want a candidate
or two better two from these key states
they don't they want people this is why
Trump is so popular they want somebody
who does not play by the marcus of
Queensbury rules they are so sick of
john mccain saying i'm not going to
mention reverend wright why not they do
against you they ran a commercial
against you that showed you that you
didn't remember that you had eleven
houses and Mitt Romney said you know we
don't want it we want to run this
campaign a certain way and I think 30
seconds after he said that they had a
commercial of a african-american
sanitation worker saying I pick up his
garbage in San Diego and he never comes
out and has coffee with me the next
commercial showed him with a dog pin on
his a cartoon of a dog thing on his car
when they got through of him they turned
a very nice gifted person into an
absolute greedy old white monster and he
kept saying we're not when kandi Crawley
hijacked that debate and abandoned her
role as a disinterested moderator and
became a partisan you thought he was
gonna grab that the microphone said how
dare you and he didn't do it I think
they they need somebody like the old Lee
out water who turned I mean in a very
cruel way but he when he got done with
Michael Dukakis George HW Bush looked
like Ronald Reagan and you're gonna have
to either give up on the presidency or
gonna have to
that type of deterrent politics so you
need somebody that has Trump's attitude
but is informed and I think right now it
seems to me that there's that Rubio and
Christie and maybe Walker and Cruz and
Fiorina count in that sense you need
somebody that really knows the issues
they all do you need somebody that has
experience I tend it and I think you do
too
would prefer somebody maybe with some
executive experience in theory the best
ticket so far seems to be Fiorina and
Rubio may be Rubio at the top only
because we that I said we don't want
somebody we haven't had somebody since
Eisenhower with no political experience
so and what is the election going to
turn on it's going to turn on an issue
that we don't know yet and getting back
this calculus I touched on it's going to
be how well the Democrats are going to
be able to say the Republicans represent
white privilege a dominant white male
seventy percent of the country that time
has passed by and how well that will
energize minorities to vote for somebody
who is not Barack Obama and the ticket
and how many people who are so-called
Reagan Democrats conservative working
class mostly whites get sick of it and
say enough is enough and I'm gonna vote
for a Republican and if that that latter
number is over sixty five percent then
it doesn't really matter how many people
are voter fraud it won't matter the
Democrats will lose and if it's not
they'll win and without thank you very
much
Thank You Victor we have about 10 or 15
minutes for questions if you have a
question raise your hand and we have a
student with a microphone since this
event is being streamed on the Internet
we would like to be able to get the
question before the answer so put your
hand up and she will come by you and
Victor will answer from here so his
voice can be heard as well I would also
note that in the lobby afterwards
there's a gonna be a small reception
folks are welcome to stay and continue
the conversation with dr. Hanson for a
little while but we do have about 10 or
15 minutes for questions right now
Esther Esther Oh Bertha Competitive
Enterprise Institute Dean I found very
frustrating 3 hours a long time but
virtually nothing other than our
macroeconomic problems big big debts and
so forth but nothing about the
regulatory state nothing about how we're
going to disentangle this labyrinth of
any entrepreneurial things and it's and
at the military side a lot of a lot of
discussion of the military foreign
policy side but there was no real
attempt to say how much can we afford
are there any boundaries from America
doing everything around the world it was
sort of we care we can do it all it
sounded to me as very shallow on both
the economic and the foreign policy side
I agree with you and that was no more
evident when they talked about Social
Security and Trump suggested that people
in his income bracket not take it that
will have no effect on something I
turned 62 last week and I looked at how
much I'm gonna get for Social Security
and then I look at what my children are
making and what they take out and I say
to myself that's not sustainable and the
only answer is that that people in our
age group are gonna have to privately
off-the-record recycle or Social
Security to our children who are paying
it because otherwise it's not
sustainable and the budget as I said
it's gonna be 20 trillion dollars and
why the Federal Reserve did not raise it
we can't even raise the interest rates
up to 1% because to do so the service on
the debt would be
I mean if you get up to 5% we're gonna
be losing 500 to 600 billion dollars for
debt service and then think about it
Barack Obama has exhausted the arsenal
usually when you want to solve a a slow
economy you do two or three things you
you get interest rates to nothing or low
and then you have big deficits and then
the economy kicks in and creates revenue
and you get back again but we've already
done that we've shot all those arrows in
our quiver the zero interest rate has
not helped the economy that much and he
says he's a success because we have the
largest number of dollars coming in
greatest number of revenue we've ever
had this last quarter because of the in
tax rate up to thirty nine point five
back way above Reagan levels back to
Bill Clinton's levels on top income and
we got the deficit down from one point
four trillion three trillion down to
five hundred billion and we call that
success and it's not it's not
sustainable and yet in the military
you're right about the candidates we're
going to be down to three percent GDP
and we're gonna have a smaller fleet and
the number of ships since World War one
and that's not sustainable unless the
strategic responsibility and vision so
those candidates should have said one of
three things
I admired Carly Fiorina she said we have
to get this many ships and battalions
sounded great but what she didn't tell
us was and here's how I'm gonna pay for
and if you don't want to pay for it
these are the following countries that
we're gonna pull back from so the irony
is that everybody's making fun of Trump
because he lives in a fantasy world of
no facts and yet the people who advance
facts in some ways are just as
fantastical that's a good point in last
night's debate one of the candidates I
don't remember who in one of the
candidates I don't recall who described
Iran as being America's greatest
existential threat at this point and
almost all the candidates with the
possible exception of Rand Paul seemed
to agree and let the conversation go in
that direction
do you agree and if not what for it from
a foreign policy perspective where
should we be looking well I think what
Rand Paul is saying
that when we had this discussion in the
90s under Bill Clinton and the same
people who negotiated the Iran deal most
of them negotiated the North Korean deal
so Rand Paul if he were here I wouldn't
want to misrepresent him I think he'd
say well all you alarmist said that if
North Korea gets a nuke and now they
have seven or eight of them and they
have a missile capability then we'd be
dead and you know what they're not
because China will deter him or
something so he would say even if they
get a nuke people as mainstream as
Abizaid said that I disagree because I
think it's a revolutionary society Iran
is and we've all be always been told
that Sunni Wahhabi Islamic terrorism is
not state it may be stealthily advanced
by Saudi Arabia or Pakistan but it
doesn't have it's not a state and that
therefore it doesn't have the capability
Rann is a state and we know that the
Shia brand of radical Islam is a little
bit more unstable or messianic let's say
and Iran has a visceral hatred of us so
when Obama says that by bringing it into
the fold of Nations and releasing this
money that has been impounded and
allowing this thirty billion dollars of
oil to be sold they're gonna be China
eyes in other words the consumer class
will moderate the I don't see there's
any historical evidence for that people
said the same thing about Hitler only 5%
of the Germans are Nazis you know get
given the Rhineland Austria and finally
nobody in their right mind would go down
that road and they didn't realize that
Hitler was not Kaiser Wilhelm and the
Nazis were not Prussian Junkers and this
Iranian theocratic group may do things
that are illogical Obama thinks they
were nobody would be so stupid to cause
a nuclear exchange but that assumes they
share his logic and the premises have
been logic if you're one of them and you
believe that Israel is a one bomb state
and that 50 million people dying is not
that
bad because they're all gonna go to a
better place anyway and that Iran would
survive and if they did do that for the
next millennium the mantle of Islamic
supremacy would be transferred from the
Sunnis to the only country the only
country that had the guts ie
a Shia theocracy then it makes some
sense so I'm very worried about it I
don't know if they're subject to the
traditional deterrent laws of deterrence
dr. Hansen yep in addition to that
particular issue is also the change that
we have in this agreement in terms of if
Israel attacks Iran and our position
relative to have you defend Iran at that
point I'm not sure if people understand
that at this point well I think you're
referring and I did read the entire
treaty I tried to convince our local
congressman and he and I had an email
exchange last week he's voting for it
and there wasn't an element I don't know
the exact number and that said that the
United States is committed to protecting
the sanctity of the protocols and that
would be an logically interpreted that
we're not going to allow a cyber attack
on the centrifuges from Israel and we
probably you could also interpret that
as we would discourage Israel from
preemptively bombing because of of this
protocol and yet what's ironic about
that is our own State Department and our
own president said we cannot include or
bundle or in parasitical fashion things
like Hezbollah or Hamas or terrorism
that's outside the agreement and yet
there's things in that agreement that go
way beyond just the question of
ballistic missile now the $64,000
question is is Obama a naive that
doesn't understand what classical wolves
of warfare have been it doesn't
understand why people go to war and why
they fight it and how they lose or win
or is he more dangerous and he has some
unhinged notion that Iran could be a
strategic partner of the United States
and balance us with the
Sooni monarchies they believe that and
with Israel and therefore that we could
be playing both sides and that's a very
if that's true then I don't have much
hope at all it's gonna be very dangerous
I think a couple more questions this
will be our final question dr. Hanson do
you have any opinion on the probability
of there being a pre-election surprise
or an October Surprise that might entail
something like an Obama impeachment or
having looked up Jade helm on Google
there's been some talk of martial law
taking place anything like that I don't
know if would be that dramatic everybody
remembers one of October surprise it is
it's an event that an incumbent
president has the power to shape or
massage in a way that he thinks will
enhance his re-election or his successor
the same party's election and it's an
old trick I'll give you one example in
1942 we were at war and we had been at
war for about 11 months and Franklin
Roosevelt was very worried about the
midterm election for two reasons one he
promised that we weren't going to go to
war
but then the euphoria the euphoric anger
after I shouldn't say you for it gets
knock some more but the anger after
Pearl Harbor we hadn't done anything yet
so we were going to invade North Africa
operation I think it was husky and we
were going to land at Morocco and he was
pushing the whole time in the accident
George Marshall got angry he said you
know what we can't get this landing
before that November all think it was so
we ended up landing five three or four
days after the election but the
Roosevelt administration was trying to
you know make the election more
important than the strategic safety of
our soldiers to go in and that was a
very common thing all the Republicans
accused the him of doing that all during
the war and of course
the white Eisenhower when he ran in 1952
he never forgave Matthew Ridgway who had
saved Korea because he did not want he
saved Korea after the loss of so lead we
took it after the invasion of the
Chinese across the Yellow River and then
Ridgeway took all of South Korean he's
saved he was back on the 38th parallel
and Eisenhower was running on the idea
that he'd bugged out if he got back
South Korea why not take the other and
he knew that we weren't going to do that
but he ran and ran and ran and there was
some hint that the the Truman
administration put pressure or thought
that that Ridgeway under no
circumstances should do anything but sit
there and not try to affect the the war
in a way that that would confirm what
Eisenhower was an advocate of course
Eisenhower got elected anyway and then
he didn't do anything different than
Truman did and we had that big
controversy with the Reagan
administration in 1980 Gary what's his
name Salk sit he's he made the argument
that the Reagan administration was
trying to cut a deal with the Iranians
to not release the hostages until after
the election so Carter would look weak
and that was refuted but on the other
hand there were suggestions that Carter
himself was willing to do things that he
wouldn't of other thighs done because if
he got the hostages released and what am
I getting at every president is accused
of this and I and I'll give you one last
example and shut up in the 2012
re-election and mid-september we had
Benghazi and that refuted the slogan GM
is alive and Osama bin Laden is dead
that al Qaeda was no longer existent
because of the brilliance of Barack
Obama and so they advanced a narrative
it wasn't al Qaeda it's dead
we didn't have to beef up Benghazi
embassy because there's no threat it was
a spontaneous riot created by one of
those right-wing video makers
Nakula Nakula so they went out and
jailed a guy on a minor probation put
him in jail for a year and then over the
dead bodies Hillary said it was a riot
we'll get the filmmaker they knew at the
time that was not true
and yet they had needed that election
point and now the controversy that I
think it will happen with the big naazy
hearings is to what degree did they
compromise David Petraeus who made a
number of assertions both under oath in
private sessions with the Intelligence
Committee but also publicly that that
was a spontaneous riot and the Obama
administration was correct and then as
soon as that talking point defuse the
issue the campaign issue was at five to
four days after the election he resigned
and he resigned in scandal that
apparently was known in August and again
the question was they had compromised a
CIA to get the election quiet about
Benghazi and so what I'm getting at is
it wouldn't be unusual in American
history if Obama is invested in a
particular candidate to try to do a big
deal and he's talked about certain deals
that he's he's interested in one of them
was the Iran the Cuba deal maybe he
could reset with Putin or something
my own theory is that Obama's a
narcissist and he's a nihilistic
narcissist and he's not willing to do
anything for anybody unless he knows
that that will further his own
reputation and legacy so if Joe Biden
word Iran and were to be nominated and
were to be in a close race I think that
would be very likely that he would look
to a foreign policy coup to help Biden
but not with Hillary Clinton I think
it's a it's a legitimate speculation
that he would prefer Republican to win
over Hillary because I don't think he
thinks that she's gonna run on his
legacy that he knows her better than we
do and and he knows that she's going to
run against him and say she's gonna
bring back the Renaissance of 1992 to
2000 under her hood
once she gets nominated she will do that
thank you